ligne et aucune femme au panthéon c'est
nier ce que dans le passé les femmes ont
apporté à la patrie
1992 simone veil conteste l'absence de
femmes au panthéon à cette époque seule
une famille repose ou plutôt une seule
épouse sophie berthelot y entrent en
1907 en qualité de femme de son mari
marcelin berthelot un grand chimiste
marcelin berthelot meurt de chagrin
lorsque sophie c'est un impensable de se
séparer dans l'au delà leur voeu sera
exaucé on surnommera sophie berthelot
l'inconnu du panthéon la première à y
entrer pour ses qualités propres c'est
marie curie la physicienne deux fois
prix nobel est l'épousé honnie zay en
1995 avec son mari le physicien pierre
curie par françois mitterrand mais il
est un autre symbole qui retient ce soir
l'attention de la nation celui du combat
exemplaire d'une femme qui a décidé
d'imposer ses capacités dans une société
qui réserve aux hommes les fonctions
intellectuelles et les responsabilités
publiques et dans une société qui a nié
ces grandes femmes les faire entrer au
panthéon c'est un peut réparer
l'histoire deux grandes résistantes vont
ensuite y entrer deux amis geneviève de
gaulle anthonioz après la guerre
commence son combat contre la pauvreté
militante des droits de l'homme la nièce
du général fonde à d'été quart monde une
association qu'elle présidera pendant
plus de trente ans et germaine tillon
pionnière de l'ethnologie
germaine tillion a parcouru le monde
pour en dénoncer les crimes pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale elles se sont
connues au camp de concentration de
ravensbrück en allemagne et c'est
ensemble que françois hollande décide de
leur entrée au panthéon en 2015 deux
femmes qui se sont battues pour
l'émancipation
et la dignité humaine qui n'ont jamais
dévié jamais abandonné jamais renoncer
oui ces deux femmes là ont leur place au
panthéon une autre femme a eu sa place
au panthéon simone veil l'avant dernière
à y être entré en 2010 huit rescapés de
la shoah auteur de la loi sur
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
première présidente du parlement
européen et pour la première fois
l'histoire s'inverse c'est donc une
femme qui permettra à son mari antoine
veil d'entrer au panthéon en tant
qu'etat dans la crypte du panthéon 76
personnalités y reposent soixante et
onze hommes cinq femmes tissent avec
l'entrée de joséphine baker première
femme noire au panthéon aux grands
hommes la patrie reconnaissante peut-on
lire sur le fronton du monument aux
grandes femmes aussi désormais
[Musique]